Good morning, John. In your last video, you
were able to quite successfully point out
that Ima Hogg and Harry Baals were able to
overcome the poor decision-making skills of
their parents and become successful people
despite their ridiculous names.
And maybe Chris P Bacon would never have become
a successful composer if it weren't for his
ridiculous name, but... you know, it's kind
of the job of a parent to, uh, help a child
avoid unnecessary anguish. And let's be honest,
a bad name can be a source of significant
anguish.
So for all of you future parents and, most
importantly, your children, this is my guide
to how to name your baby properly.
First: Say it out loud. Say it out loud in
every possible permutation. And you might
want to run it by a focus group of 12-year-olds.
Like, Andrew Peacock's parents never knew,
and neither did poor Drew, until that day
in fourth grade... this is starting to sound
like a limerick.
Anyway, punchline: Droopycock.
It could have been avoided with a focus group
of 12-year-olds saying it out loud.
Second: Name your child what you will call
your child. This has been a problem for me
my entire life. I am Hank; I have always been
Hank. My whole life, my parents called me
Hank, but they named me William.
So whenever I'm at a doctor's office or at
the airport, and somebody asks me what my
name is, I sit there thinking for a second.
And I feel like a doof because this person
has just asked me what my name is, and I should
know what my name is, and they're hastily
adding me to the suspicious flyer list.
Third: If you do not speak the language where
your child will grow up, get some native language-speakers
to come in and help you.
Maybe the world wouldn't really be a better
place if there were fewer Harry Dongs out
there, but it probably would be a better place
for those Harry Dongs.
Fourth: Stop trying to be cute. I know your
name is Silva and you think it's adorable
to name your daughter "Sterling" and your
son "Hi-Ho". And I'm in this group, too; my
last name is Green and I think it'd be adorable
to have a daughter named Olive Green.
But just don't do it, because some day, Hi-Ho
Silva is going to be an adolescent and you
don't want him to have another reason to hate
you.
Five: Check for the top baby names... and
avoid them.
Names, though you might have forgotten this
in all of the excitement, have a utilitarian
purpose. They are a unique identifier that
you place upon a person so that that person
can know when people are talking to or about
that person.
If your child has the same name as 10% of
the people in their social group, I have news
for you: You have failed.
And don't just assume that if you avoid John
and Jennifer, you're all good. Lemme tell
ya, those names aren't even in the top 10
anymore. The two top baby names of 2010 were
Jacob and Isabella, and there were more Jaydens
than there were Johns.
Six: Spell like a normal person.
I don't understand why parents do this! It
doesn't change anything, it just means that
in the future, you will have to spell your
name every time anyone wants to write down
your name.
Do not name your child Mykul [Michael], or
Kayt [Kate], or Jaucshuwa [Joshua], or Quathyryn
[Katherine]!
Seventh and last rule: Name your child a freaking
name.
Do not name your child after a comic book
character, or an item of clothing, or a profession,
or — most importantly — do not name it
after some virtue that they will enjoy all
too much rebelling against in their early
teens, like Chastity.
Okay, and this is the actual final rule: There
are no rules. Let's be honest, Harry Baals
and Ima Hogg prove that you are not your name
and it doesn't really matter.
A bad name really probably won't lead to anything
except a little bit of extra adolescent angst.
And let's be honest, adolescents are gonna
find their angst somewhere; they might as
well find it in their name.
John, I will see you tomorrow.
Endscreen. I just got my immunizations from
Haiti. The one is Bugs Bunny and the other
is Scooby Doo.
Ow! I'm going to be in Haiti in, like, a week's
time, which means that I'm going to be in
Miami in less than a week's time, so if you've
not bought your tickets, you should. It's
very possible that we won't have any for sale
at the door, so you should definitely buy
in advance.